[Música]
o delegado já que nós estamos falando em
viagem no tempo
eu quero fazer também uma viagem no
espaço e lembrar que nós estamos andando
a mais ou menos 108 109 mil quilômetros
por hora numa nave espacial chamada
planeta terra e é sobre isso que eu
quero pensar que com vocês e imaginar
algumas possibilidades problemas
desafios e ao mesmo tempo soluções como
é que o mundo vai estar em 2050 em
termos de população no mínimo 9 bilhões
de habitantes se vai a 9 mail 10 já
algumas outras previsões que significa
isso
9 bilhões de habitantes na face da terra
quantos habitantes nós temos hoje sete
milhões e meio ambiente foram 96 nós
vamos crescer 2 milhões dois milhões e
meio em 30 anos
se você tiver uma conta vocês vão ver
quantos novas crianças bebês estão
nascendo no dia de hoje sempre com sinal
de antena
vocês terem uma idéia de quantos novas
crianças ou novos seres humanos
nasceram hoje até o final do dia
alguém tem uma idéia 70 o que atenta
pessoa
se vocês é fácil fazer a conta né
dois milhões e meio de vida e por 30
depois de vídeo por 360 na guarda 220
duzentos 230 mil habitantes nasceram no
dia de hoje
se eu começar o dia todo
o que significa isso significa a cidade
de são carlos na cento o que significa
que nós vamos ter que aguentar esses
novos seres humanos estão 220 230 mil
novos seres humanos
qual é a demanda que é que se espera a
2.050 60% mais alimentos esse é o
crescimento da demanda alimentar e em
energia 50% água 40%
então vejo aqui nós temos uma tempestade
perfeita
quer dizer se a tempestade que 9 bilhões
de habitantes crescimento de 2 bilhões 2
milhões e meio
não é uma coisa simples né
e depois tudo junto a alimentos e
energia água à população longevidade
mudanças climáticas
isso aqui chama que nós chamamos de um
nexus nexus porque a independência entre
esses elementos com componentes essa
interdependência depende dessas relações
entre as coisas por exemplo santo
energia disponível e barato eu posso
limpar a água e produzir alimentos e
assim vai todos os raciocínios vocês
podem fazer as coisas estão conectadas
não há os economistas concordam que não
há solução ainda para esse problema
nós estamos sem solução a humanidade não
sabe resolver essa situação o
crescimento da população e essa demanda
das três coisas essenciais que é
alimento água e energia
talvez forma um complexo no mínimo
nós vamos a lidar com a escassez lidar
com a complexidade
e criar governança pra isso do contrário
não vão conseguir novo portanto como que
o alimento água energia estão nexus
agora minha pergunta nexus em next
o nexus comércio por exemplo nexo sem
nexo queimadas poluição da água erosão
compactação maus tratos a animais
desemprego exploração do homem pelo
homem
isso é nexus em next olha o que cabe ao
brasil subir 40% do crescimento da
demanda mundial de alimentos até 2050 no
crescimento da demanda aquilo que nós
vamos usar a mais de alimentos brasil
terá que superar quase a metade dos veja
o papel do brasil
veja a responsabilidade que está caindo
sob os nossos ombros neste momento e nos
próximos anos
a pergunta é nós vamos conseguir fazer
isso então vamos olhar 40 anos atrás a
projetar os 30 anos à frente
se nós olharmos a agricultura brasileira
ela conseguiu crescer 500% em produção
crescendo só 70% da área plantada em
grãos né
isso significou uma economia ambiental
floresta que não foi derrubada de 150
milhões de hectares que a 150 milhões de
hectares é metade da área hoje cultivada
com grãos toda a área cultivada com
grãos hoje 65 milhões de hectares
isso é mais que o dobro que foi
economizado do ponto de vista das
florestas
então com a solução intensificação e
produtividade aumento da produtividade
isso é que explica essa situação nós
produzimos aí uma tonelada por hectare e
agora nós estamos produzindo
4 5 6 toneladas por hectare dependendo
da cultura
esse trabalho aqui do grupo da embrapa
com o ministério da agricultura mostra
claramente em uma década uma série
histórica a contribuição para a produção
hoje para produzir em agricultura o que
pesa o trabalho à terra e à tecnologia
veja o que aconteceu em 95/96 trabalho
31%
até lá ela passou para 22
depois terra 18 passou para 10 e
tecnologia de 51 para 68
os dados atuais que deve ser o novo novo
censo deve dar quase 80% da tecnologia
então para explicar a produção nós vamos
e tecnologia
então isso é fundamental a ciência e
tecnologia na produção agrícola mas isso
não acabou que vem agora a revolução
digital automação inteligência
artificial impressão 3d dele data e
tecnologia 5g robôs veículos autônomos
as tecnologias convergentes primeira vez
na história da civilização humana que o
homem controla os beats controlo gente
controla a os átomos e moléculas através
até da tecnologia da informação da
comunicação da biotecnologia
nanotecnologia eo novo horizonte próximo
que dá senso comitivas a ideia tem
inteligência artificial neurolinguística
as ciências humanas e assim por dentro
de beleza uma nova agricultura mais
inteligente precisa sustentável
a união do campo com as cidades novos
negócios e oportunidades de emprego
principalmente agora para as mulheres e
para os jovens
portanto vamos perder isso de vista como
uma coisa positiva porque são carlos
está fazendo em ciência e tecnologia
para o brasil e para o mundo
nós estamos desenvolvendo sistemas de
agricultura de precisão nanotecnologia
o cheio a a pecuária sustentável a
integração lavoura pecuária que é esse
exemplo aí vocês estão vendo ali milho
vocês estão vendo eucalipto estão vendo
braquiária um pânico eo gado nelore né
são criações nossas adaptações tropicais
e dessas três componentes em que a soma
um mais um mais um é igual a 3
é mais que 3 a uma sinergia a é
importante nesse sistema então este é um
resultado fundamental já existe 15
milhões de hectares no brasil usando
essa tecnologia foi a beleza pagamento
de serviço ambiental e suave a beleza
com outras possibilidades avançadas da
economia da economia verde e assim por
diante
eu quero lembrar que o br/pas do
portinari porque ele significa muita
coisa o agro guerra ou paz
nós estamos do lado a paz mas tem muita
coisa de guerra modo né
essa imagem e som dois painéis na
painéis na verdade separados que estão
na sede da onu em nova york
o portinari quando fez isso ele pensou
vamos colocar o quadro da guerra na
entrada da onu e na saída da paz
a imagem o símbolo é muito importante
paz justiça e vida estão aí
representados alegria à saúde a morte o
desespero
antes de determinar
eu quero pensar um pouco com vocês
quais são os nexos ou nexo ou nexus
nexus que faz nexo e pra falar isso é eu
tenho uma trajetória pessoal de trabalho
e de vivência é uma vez que eu nasci
aqui numa fazenda
é no alto da serra de analândia em que
eu aprendi logo cedo com os meus pais a
lidar com a agricultura e com a natureza
isso foi muito importante e os meus pais
sempre pensava que a educação era alguma
coisa importante e fez com que eu e
minha família pudesse estudar
no entanto nesse processo de educação eu
pude conhecer uma pessoa sensacional e
infância o resto da minha vida as
pessoas são o professor sérgio
mascarenhas família dele inclusive está
aqui
dona ivone fez brilhante apresentação da
história de são carlos das ciências
professor sérgio defraudou as cortinas
do horizonte pra mim quais horizonte os
olhos da ciência
ele abriu a cortina para que eu pudesse
pensar a agricultura pensar na natureza
usando a ciência e como é um gigante ele
me colocou em homens de outros gigantes
daí eu conhecer o professorado salam e
pode trabalhar em trieste prêmio nobel
de física
depois na agricultura um doutor eliseu
aos dos fundadores da embrapa
depois o ministro roberto rodrigues
ex-ministro luiz carlos guedes ao são
paulo nery e essas pessoas então e
permitiram que eu pudesse olhar um pouco
mais à frente
se as coisas não funcionaram
a seguir a minha não falta de luz ou de
altura das freiras
não vamos à calma e nexo nexus que faz
next cultivar ciência e tecnologia para
conhecer a natureza aprender com ela e
tê-la como aliada incondicional integral
ea tecnologia da informação e da
comunicação da biotecnologia ea
nanotecnologia com as ciências
cognitivas das ciências humanas
vamos fazer um grande papel para levar
as instituições século 19 ao século 21
em paralelo o que eu faço o seguinte
tecnologia está no século 21 o homem o
mais sete está no século 20
nossa mentalidade do século 20
tecnologia no século 21 e as
instituições no século 19
então nós teremos que transformar essas
instituições
e o homem é que terá que fazer isso e
colocá-los no século da tecnologia que é
esse o século da revolução digital
século 21 ajudar o brasil eu monto a
encontrar soluções sustentáveis e
resilientes para o nexo alimento água e
energia não está resolvido teremos que
resolver essa gente pensar na existência
humana ajudar o brasil a cumprir sua
extraordinária missão de alimentar o
mundo e seu celeiro do mundo a gerar a
paz a alegria ea esperança entre os
homens
eu quero agora terminar dizendo que eu
sou muito feliz está vivo e podendo
continuar a atuar nesse momento
histórico da civilização humana é um
grande privilégio
eu gostaria de convidar todos vocês para
que a gente possa unir as forças e fazer
isso junto
fazer o quê juntos melhorar o mundo
nós rezamos e poderemos melhorar o mundo
usando as tecnologias do conhecimento e
melhorando o mundo pra que aquele seja
menos tóxico mais saudável menos nocivo
mais suave e melhorar o mundo pra que
aquele tenha também harmonia entre os
homens ea natureza iluminados pela
ciência
muito obrigado
[Música]
[Aplausos]